what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and it looks like doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness is
actually going to be bigger than we
thought it was now of course we already
knew that this movie was going to be a
massive movie this is a movie that is on
the level of avengers infinity war
avengers in-game spider-man no way home
and the repercussions of this movie are
going to affect the entirety of the mcu
plus the multiverse is going to be
completely burst open so this is one of
those once in a lifetime event and as it
turns out it does look like it might
actually have bigger repercussions than
we thought as the living tribunal has
been revealed in one of the trailers for
multiverse of madness and it is very
very clear they put the living tribunal
right in front of your face where you
can see him the only question is will he
be issuing judgment against dr strange
or could it possibly be the scarlet
witch that he's going after or maybe
both and the illuminati's name has
officially been name dropped in one of
the trailers as well and we know for a
fact that they are indeed going to judge
dr strange so let's break down this new
footage that we have and of course if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos so we have a new trailer where
they name drop the illuminati and then
another promo where we can see the
living tribunal's head if you miss them
here you
[Music]
go 10 days
nothing can prepare you
for the truth
everything you've ever known led you to
this moment
stephen strange the illuminati will see
you now
marvel studios dr strange read the pg-13
seat in premium large format in imax may
6th
mr strange
[Music]
now i for one can't really believe that
they actually showed the living tribunal
in one of these promotions this is a
cosmic entity one of the strongest
beings in the entire universe and
multiverse in fact the living tribunal's
job is pretty much to monitor the
multiverse and this actually sort of
lines up with mordo the variant of morta
that we have been seeing at least
because i do believe that this is master
mordo like the toys call him i don't
think he's the same mortal for our
universe but we'll wait and see on that
regardless in the first doctor strange
film r mordo is training stephen strange
and he explains that some magic is too
powerful to contain so they have relics
and here's our first name drop this is a
relic
some magic is too powerful to sustain so
we imbue objects with it
allowing them to take the strain we
cannot
this
is the staff
of the living tribunal
there are many relics
the wand of a tomb the vaulting boots of
valtor so it seems the living tribunal
already gave some of his power to mordo
and that's very interesting because now
mordo seems to be the one kind of
protecting the multiverse as a part of
the illuminati however ultimately if
things get too out of hand that's where
the living tribunal comes in and it
looks like that's exactly what we're
going to see in multiverse of madness
the living tribunal is an insanely
powerful cosmic entity who has existed
as long as the universe itself like i
mentioned before his job is to
essentially safeguard the multiverse
whether that's keeping the balance of
mystical forces keeping the balance of
good and evil or simply stopping one
universe from hurting another universe
that is his job however it usually takes
something insanely big for him to appear
and issue judgment and as many people
know the living tribunal has three
different faces the front face from
which it usually speaks out of
represents equity the fully hooded face
on the right side represents necessity
and the partially hooded face on the
left represents revenge and here's what
is interesting and what might actually
save steven strange all three voices
must agree on a single case before the
tribunal can intervene so it is possible
that mordo perhaps summons the living
tribunal to judge dr strange and also
the scarlet witch but like i mentioned
all three have to agree on the case so
perhaps all three faces don't agree that
steven strange should simply be
obliterated because that's the power of
the living tribunal he can obliterate an
entire planet from a single bolt from
his fingers and it makes you wonder if
he's actually going to go up against the
scarlet witch or should i say if the
scarlet witch is actually going to go up
against him because the scarlet witch is
now probably the most powerful being in
the entire universe and multiverse but
is she strong enough to go up against a
cosmic entity we'll have to wait and see
on that but i do really really hope she
does fight the living tribunal that
would be epic now what's interesting
about this tv spot that shows the living
tribunal is that it actually looks like
the three heads that it has are separate
it does kind of look like they are
traveling throughout different parts of
the multiverse and then they actually
run into the living tribunal however
like i mentioned since he is the judge
of the multiverse i doubt they just
randomly run into him also it's worth
noting that there are no variants of the
living tribunal there's not one living
tribunal for our universe another for
another one another for another one and
there's not an infinite amount of living
tribunals and infinite universes there
is one that looks over the entire
multiverse however he can exist in
multiple different universes at the same
time making it appear like he has
variants but it is all just him it seems
like a variant but it's really just him
existing simultaneously in different
universes all the same person all the
same mind but the three different heads
actually show us that perhaps the mcu is
going to betray the living tribunal just
a little bit differently than we know
him from the comics it's also worth
noting that america chavez is with
doctor strange here and she might be on
trial as well as she has the ability to
open portals to different universes so
needless to say doctor strange along
with america chavez and along with him
thinking he is getting the help from the
scarlet witch might be in pretty big
trouble in the eyes of the living
tribunal however since the scarlet witch
is basically going to be using steven
strange in the beginning of the film
when doctor strange doesn't know that
she's kind of evil this might actually
be the loophole that he needs to get out
of the judgment of the living tribunal
because one of them might say well he
didn't know that she was evil it's not
entirely his fault he didn't mean to
destroy the multiverse because i'm going
to assume that the main problem is going
to be the scarlet witch but how will the
living tribunal see it and how will the
illuminati see it because in this new
trailer that has been released like we
saw doctor strange is in handcuffs being
escorted somewhere by the ultron bots
and then we see mordo with the ultron
bots behind him and he says the
illuminati will see you now of course
from here we have the scene where doctor
strange walks into the chamber and he
sees all of the chairs and professor x
rolls up and says we should tell him the
truth now we still don't officially know
what the truth is but i'm assuming it's
the fact that the scarlet witch is
really evil either that or it's the fact
that the illuminati are the ones who
truly run the entire multiverse and
oversee everything probably alongside
the living tribunal and maybe some other
cosmic entities but it does seem like
the illuminati really are kind of a
judgment panel here of course some of
the members are some of the most
strongest and powerful beings in the
entire multiverse but i'm assuming most
of the time they probably wouldn't want
to fight that's why they have the ultron
bots but the living tribunal a cosmic
entity being in multiverse of madness
implies that the universe of the mcu is
about to expand which makes sense
because a lot of things are being
introduced to the mcu right now like the
egyptian gods and not to mention the
greek gods coming and thor love and
thunder might as well throw the
universal cosmic entities in there to
show us that the mcu has really just
begun there's a vast amount of stories
and characters that we have yet to
explore so the mcu is looking bright and
let me know what you think about the
living tribunal appearing in multiverse
of madness leave your thoughts and
excitement in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest news for live updates you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof